il fottutissimo giorno è arrivato era
aprile del 2019 quando andai in giappone
con gianandrea doveva riuscire ad aprire
il 2009 soprattutto il forever e io
pensai quindi tempo che tornano già
fatto tutti e me la cia pinter super
meat boy forever è uscito a dicembre che
giorno è oggi il 5 gennaio 2021 si
lamentava mia prof che portavo i compiti
in ritardo cioè ma io non ho parole
poi vabbè fin qua cero amico mio bene
[Musica]
basta manera
ma con final day
[Musica]
poi è uscito ragazzi è uscito figlia
come sono gasato come nel summit è la
canzone che mi fa cacciare con la
scimmia perché i ragazzi c'è scritto
world generators air viaggerà l'altro
casa vivo minecraft primo livello di un
lungo casinò che arriverà con supermeet
wipo renderle schema stanno avanti da
sole non succederà niente ragazza non
davanti da solo aiuto e tipo ed i ma
allora mai tutto il gioco così se tu non
decidi quando andare avanti decide lui e
tipo geometri dash come le parole e
vaffan cuore nome a rifare ok perfetto
quindi ha spiegato ma questa cosa perché
non ho capito o mi si è inceppato il
joystick e non lo so però non ne sono
sicuro ti ha fatto benedetto e vabbè
indietro so tornato e non o non so
questa cosa perfavore dati spiegatemi
spiegatemelo non ho capi eccolo da meno
se lo porta via ogni volta e quindi ma
veramente avrebbe così come l'altro
perché andare avanti dicevi tu vuoi
andare avanti
che musica è poi questo spiega te lo
vedi tu puoi stare scillato tutto il
giorno e fa lui
tre parole ok è un po è diverso come
gameplay
ok africa pupugnao però allora scusami
non posso trovare i segreti perché tanto
la via è una sola corretto che c'e solo
la via possono andare avanti ha portato
corpo del demonio madonna che pro gay
merger tra queste avente un casino ma è
rosso è rincoglionito nord ok non ci
arrivo ci sono
perfetto allora è molto severamente un
incrocio tra geometri dash super meat
boy normalmente bene benissimo le forze
che erano campate lo devo semplicemente
strisciare con l'amore ok strisciando kg
pugni in automatico non è vero va avanti
la sola varia assicuro che è un disastro
se è veramente idee va bè ragazzi è
possibile
[Musica]
madonna cosa ha fatto e va beh sono
stupido ma allora col fatto che va
avanti da solo mi sembrava più facile ma
col cacchio e un design o ok perfetto ma
posso anche riposarmi ai media negli
angoli va beh meno male perché sennò è
un disastro
e come salgono non ci posso salire li
hanno invece si possono dire lo stupido
se non tocco prima porco del demonio ma
preziosa proprio puoi far correre
indietro e basta che ci divertirà
professore quando vado a sinistra dello
schermo ma ci sono rame che cosa vuoi
porca [ __ ]
ora italians ecco questi questi sono gli
unici modi in cui puoi perdere tempo
perché effettivamente
rimane ferma e va bene però non ne avete
non ne sto vedendo altri quindi è un po
più semplice e grado di timing
dell'altro e solo difficile uguale a
livello di fattibilità alle volte anche
di più porco del demonio
ok non ho capito lo devo fare un
pannello fare qua ho messo un'ora ma a
posto ok
l'uomo perfetto perfetto che si e gia
sporca di sangue non ho fatto niente
figurati alla sporca già di suo che devo
fare la devo tornare indietro
mammamia disastro non di altro ok
perfetto addio santissimo no ragazzi
queste che si staccano sono male con un
quello di gotto vabbè suicidio cosa va
fare qui lo devo andare non ci passo
solo fare spiega mi ha una sega devo
andare sotto prima che con lo si metta
in posizione per bloccarli ok ok quindi
adesso figli adesso perfetto l'esca raga
è bellissimo è veramente bellissimo ma
mette un sia terribile ce mettemo è
veramente di cio lanzi a giocare è un
casino
porca vacca se non farmi anche aiutare
dalle stesse lame che vi fanno il culo
c'è pensate e questo il primo mondo ai
ragazzi e mezzo tutorial madonna come me
la sono vista bruttini stima jackie di
troppo
dai porca vacca
juan angel e juan angelo è un guaio
klina yoga queste ragazze appena e
fitness comunque ragazzi perché hanno
scelto sta roba di far andare il
personaggio avanti da solo è stranissimo
cioè proprio la meccanica strana per un
hit boyle non avrei mai immaginato la
parte nera l'avevo visto video gameplay
di niente quindi è tutta una sorpresa
però strano per una roba strana aiuto le
ricorrere sono morti perché dove vado
dovevate perché ci vado non ci vado cosa
devo fare qua moderne a guarda cosa
faccio
muoio voglio fare qui scusatemi quello
che ho fatto prima e giusto
no abbiamo di castro
non ho idea di cosa dice prima ho fatto
questa cosa ok è invece quello che gira
carlos el topo che tira madonna cosa ha
fatto ti prego di morire non sapevo bene
come restarvi perfetto
spero che sia arrivato perché non vedo
non vedo neanche poi quando arrivano ok
questo non c'è poi perché meno male
perché
ok ok
eccoci boss pigs lag
non farti 6 per ora è successo
arriviamo al primo scagnozzo di superman
colpo never
e vabbè la madonna cos'è
lo vedo incazzato secondo me è un
problema questo
un giorno
sono cazzi effettiva salve ragazzi e
sarai sempre il profitto
vabbè allora a cosa riti colorita ma ok
ma no ma poverino quindi
non si capisce lo dobbiamo dobbiamo
combattere questo
perché madonna che casino adro tira i
pugni alle cose non ho capito cosa
dovrei fare qui vabbè un disastro ma
devo veramente iniziare la che non c'è
un checkpoint
cosa vuol dire ogni volta devo inizia la
causa su cosa mi significa dai no che
palle
e difficilissimo ma raga ma potete
veramente farveli iniziato a capo ogni
volta ce ne siano esagerazioni scusatemi
no dai non ci voglio credere che sfigato
mondiale dai no si no e alza e non ci
passo non ci passo come cazzolato giu
non ci passo non ci presto
no ragazzi infatti nomi
quello che stavo dati conservati
vasto il porto
u
dai ce l'ha fatta sono finito il
solissimo stato migliore di tutti da
tempi iscritti grazie che ho fatto e
quindi oggi è stato un disagio ha messo
un'ora però vabbè non è vero ora non ci
ha messo cinque minuti però sono stati
sicuri di intensi quindi si chiama da
che fàcasino come già vi vedo il
prossimo super meat boy che è super meat
boy infinite dove usano lui come
protagonista zaia
[Musica]
incazzatissimo che va nel mondo dei
morti clinica per mickey è finito audio
questo non era tipo alcuno dei monti del
vecchio super meat boy questo non
succede cos'è sta roba sembra happy tree
friends sembra troppo ragazzi sembra
troppo ept di friends parola
ma guarda non è un braccio la cosa
beh cosa vedo la pentola per ragazzi è
veramente happy tree presso bellissimo
dei ragazzi questo era il primo episodio
di super meat boy forever bellissimo c'è
veramente strano sta dinamica che si
muove da solo però è comunque difficile
uguale per noi vi sia piaciuto scegliamo
la ricorda bisogno di super meat boy
ragazzi come mi piace anche vari social
che come trascrizione se ne sono usciti
iscrivete era come sempre ci vediamo al
prossimo video bella ragazza
[Musica]
ma